La volta al món a peu, dia 241, últim dia de la meva travessa íntegrament a peu abans d'agafar un avió d'aquí quatre dies, el dia 31.
No, tres dies. Avui és dia 28 de juliol i, bueno, avui us explicaré el que faré els propers dies, us explicaré alguna cosa de Tbilisi,
ens aproparem a Tbilisi per les muntanyes, que són maques, t'aurem la vista i, bueno, gaudirem de l'últim dia de poder dir-li a la gent
he vingut des de Barcelona fins aquí caminant. Matí genial, sense sol perquè tenim núvols allà, encara millor, si no m'estaria afregint.
I no ha vingut ningú a molestar-me aquesta nit, cosa que s'agraeix.
Jorge, molt tranquil per acampar, eh? Pots acampar on vulguis tu.
Ningú et dirà res. Recullu!
Les nou i quart, sis quilòmetres caminats, queden uns 17 fins al meu hotel a Tbilisi.
Aquí tenim una espècie de bakery posada a la Google, que és forn de pa.
Bueno, a veure si tenen lavabo, que és el que ara mateix m'interessa. No pas que faci un bon cafè i bons dolços.
Doncs em passa igual que ahir, que el Google posava que estava obert.
Les finestres obertes i no, no hi ha res. I no, no, no, sembla que no podré prendre res.
Però veig aquí algunes portetes. No sé si alguna serà de lavabo. Seria molt d'amor, no, colar-me? Jo crec que sí.
Bé, segueixo i ja està.
Fa dos dies vaig posar el meu primer vídeo sense el micròfon, sinó fent servir el micròfon del mòbil.
I em vau dir que els comentaris que s'escoltava perfecte, no sé què.
Si ho escolteu als vídeos, si amb un zapatófono o amb el volum del mòbil, però si ho escoltes amb auriculars o a la tele, el so és molt pitjor.
Se senten els cotxes passar molt més, la meva veu se sent pitjor, en fi, no sé.
Però avui, avui en principi tornaré a comprar els micròfons.
A veure aquí, hi ha una porta oberta. Sembla més cerveseria que una altra cosa.
Bé, molt guapo el lloc, tenen la porta oberta, està il·luminat, però no hi ha ningú, ningú respon i res.
Un clàssic de George, eh?
Tot el tema serveis és així, l'atenció és bastant difícil.
Doncs al final he hagut d'anar a l'espart, que fan cafè, prou de cent.
Cappuccino sense sucre, important, que encara estic complint el repte.
Hi ha una espècie de triangle amb una espècie de paté al mig, no m'acaba d'agradar.
Aquest paté el tren a diversos llocs de Georgia és molt insípid.
Millor de formatge, però mira, no he pogut comunicar-me amb la venedora per saber què tenia.
Ui, que bé!
Bé, m'han deixat anar al lavabo aquesta benzinera.
Uf, m'he fet un pes de sobre, eh?
Quan camines, a vegades em fan preguntes, tipus, ostres, no has canviat el sentit de la vida?
No trobes que, no sé, quines reflexions has fet passant tant temps sol?
La veritat és que quan estàs caminant i fent travesses no penses en aquestes coses.
El que penses sobretot és en el dia a dia, en sobreviure, coses més bàsiques.
Trobar un lavabo.
No, anar a fer-ho a la muntanya, menjar, veure on hi ha l'aigua, saps?
No són preguntes molt filosòfiques, eh, les que et fas?
Ostres, mireu, les restes d'una pell de serp.
Que fort, eh?
Mireu, mireu, és una pell de serp, eh?
I jo la conec, aquesta espècie, eh?
És la Manguerus comunis.
Veieu, eh?
Això és el que deixa la serp quan...
Sí, sí, sí, heavy, eh?
Manguerus comunis i eurgianis.
He deixat la carretera i toca camí ja fins a Tiblissi.
Molt millor, eh? Molt més tranquil.
Bueno, què faré? Què faré els propers dies?
Ah, per cert, amb aquest micròfon es nota molt quan camino, se senten les passes.
Llavors intentaré caminar fluixet perquè m'escolteu bé.
Què faré a Tiblissi aquests dies?
Bueno, primer lloc, entrevistar a un català sense fronteres.
Com ja sabeu, un dels reptes és intentar entrevistar un català que visqui a cada país dels que passo.
I ja n'he localitzat un, i li faré una entrevista i pujaré el vídeo.
Després, m'afaitaré i em taeré el cabell, que ja toca, ja toca.
Ho volia fer abans, eh?
Però a Cotai si no vaig trobar cap lloc obert, així que em vingués de camí i no hagués de perdre molt de temps.
Després, he d'anar a buscar, a comprar els micròfons.
He d'enviar les postals, comprar-les, comprar els segells, escriure-les, imprimir les etiquetes, enganxar-les i enviar.
He de fer tota la feina, encara.
I aquí a Jòrgia són cares. Ja vaig preguntar a una oficina de correus i són dos euros amb setze, crec, o dos euros i poc.
Són les més cares de la volta amb una peu.
Té d'això, si saps la cosa, que el país més barat pel que vaig siguin les postals més cares.
Bé, és el que hi ha.
He de començar a tramitar el visat de Tajikistan, o com a mínim informar-me de com fer-ho a l'ambaixada de Tashkent, si no ho faig online.
He de començar, bé, ja he estat informant-me, però he de ficar-me bé amb això.
El mateix amb el visat de Pakistan, encara que bé, aquest el puc gestionar una mica més tard.
Un cop tingui el visat per Tajikistan, he de demanar el permís per al Pamir.
Això també potser no ho he de fer ara, però he de començar a veure com es fa.
Es necessita un permís especial per anar per aquella zona.
He de trobar-me amb dos catalans que estan de turisme per aquí.
Un vol fer un cafè amb mi, ok, i l'altre em porta uns mitjons del Decathlon.
Bé, si me'l trobo ja us ho explicaré.
He de rebre el sac d'aquella, com sabeu.
Bé, ara m'han arribat un parell de SMS de duanes de Georgia per gestionar-ho i, en principi, demà arribaré.
A veure si és veritat.
He de fer un vídeo una mica amb les gestions.
Vull fer un vídeo una mica amb la logística, les gestions, de tot plegat.
No sé si explicar la història de Tbilisi una mica o explicar-la avui. Encara ho he de decidir.
Què més? He de fer un directe.
Mira, hi haurà directe el dia 30 a les 7 de la tarda.
De 7 a 9, vostres, que per mi són de 9 a 11.
Mira, hi haurà directe el dia 30 a les 7 de la tarda. De 7 a 9, vostres, que per mi són de 9 a 11.
Doncs hi haurà directe.
No ho faig més tard perquè jo el dia següent he d'agafar l'avió cap a Uzbekistan.
Llavors tampoc me'n puc anar a dormir a les tantes, saps?
Llavors, dia 30, a les 7 de la tarda, ho anunciaré igualment, a les xarxes i tot plegat.
Directe, especial, he arribat fins aquí a peu.
Després he de fer un ril, he de fer un ril especial,
explicant que he arribat fins aquí a peu
i el que serà la meva ruta a Àsia.
Ho he d'explicar a Instagram.
Bueno, això és un tema de les beques Propulsió,
que s'acaben aquest 31 de juliol, és a dir, d'aquí quatre dies.
Uf, com baixa això, eh? Mireu.
I, bueno, les beques Propulsió,
a part dels diners que m'han donat a mi,
hi ha una sèrie de diners, 800 euros,
no és poc,
que s'han de dedicar a publicitat a les xarxes socials.
Potser algun m'heu descobert
amb algun anunci
que ha sortit a l'Instagram.
Que consti que jo no he fet cap anunci a YouTube.
Totes les visites que veieu al YouTube són reals,
són orgàniques.
Els vídeos a Instagram, en canvi,
hi ha alguns que he pagat
perquè tinguin més reproduccions,
perquè era obligatori a les beques.
Llavors, bueno,
em queden encara
uns 200 i pico euros
o 300
per pagar,
d'acord?
I he de fer un reel i potenciar-ho perquè, bueno,
perquè la gent em segueixi, no?
I una cosa més
he de fer, però deixeu-me acabar així això,
perquè...
rellisca i és molt empinat.
Ja està.
No m'he caigut.
Doncs mira, l'última cosa que he de fer té relació amb això.
Les sabatilles.
Porto 7 mesos,
més, fent servir les Icebook
Jarp, diversos models,
i, malauradament,
momentàniament, com a mínim,
aquí acaba la col·laboració,
no per res, sinó una mica per culpa meva,
perquè...
no els hi vaig dir, ei,
ja toca
canviar les sabatilles i a veure si me les podeu enviar.
Ho he pensat massa tard.
I, bueno,
no he pensat en el temps
que cal per enviar les sabatilles
des de Catalunya fins a Georgia,
passar duanes, no sé què...
I, bueno, també podria haver demanat a algú
que les recollís i que me les fes portar, bueno...
Total, no hi he pensat. Llavors,
doncs jo faria servir,
seguiria fent servir les Icebook Jarp,
però mira, ha passat això i
m'hauré de comprar unes noves.
I en relació a això, m'acabo de
trobar un home, a la carretera,
que anava fent running, i ha dit
Hey, wait, wait, espera!
One question, do you speak English?
I li he preguntat on podia trobar
sabatilles com les seves.
Perquè ell portava unes sabatilles molt guapes, unes
hookah, o hoca, que són
les bones. No sé si en compraria aquestes.
Vull dir que són marca bona, saps? Jo necessito
unes sabatilles que estiguin
que estiguin bé, saps?
Bueno, doncs per què li he preguntat?
I no he buscat directament al Google. Doncs perquè
quan vaig estar a Tbilisi,
ara fa una setmana
ja vaig estar mirant
botigues esportives per comprar uns mitjons
i vaig trobar
que hi havia molt poca cosa.
Molt poca selecció. Llavors,
li he preguntat, i gràcies a que li he preguntat a aquest home,
m'ha dit, mira,
als voltants del
Dinamo Arena, que és un estall de futbol
que hi ha a Tbilisi, hi ha un munt de botigues
d'esport. I sí, sí, mira, n'hi ha moltíssimes.
I fins i tot m'ha dit, n'hi ha una
que vénen sabatilles de segona mà
que estan com noves per 150
gels. 150
laris i eurians. Això és molt poc. Això són
50 euros. Bueno, no sé si
algú ho pagués de segona mà
o les de primera mà, però
molt guai saber-ho.
I a més tenen el meu número,
perquè jo gasto
una barca considerable de
i de Facebook
gasto un 46. I de Salomon,
que és una marca que talla petit,
gasto un 46 dos terços.
Primer cim
de la volta al món a peu. No m'esperava que fos aquí.
No havia ni mirat.
No és molt èpic,
però bueno, té un vèrtex geogràfic,
per tant, per tant, és un cim.
És un cim. Mireu, està escrit
en rus i té el número
185.
A més té una bandera,
té això.
Primer cim de la volta
al món a peu. No té vistes, eh? Seguim.
Fins demà!
Barcelona, Tbilisi, a peu, i en vuit mesos.
6.300 o 6.200 i pico quilòmetres, 241 dies,
i 11 països, crec.
Bé, al proper vídeo us faig el resum, d'acord?
Primer de tot, abans de fer el resum del dia, test, clean and iron, aquesta habitació.
He agafat aquesta habitació perquè no era la més barata, ni tampoc era la millor,
però era la que ens van acceptar poder rebre el paquet de DHL que he de rebre del sac de dormir.
Bé, la primera part del test seria pols.
Pols, malament, malament, mireu.
Aquesta taula, no sé si es veu, està ple de pols.
I una cosa que m'agrada d'aquesta habitació és que tenen un esfraier,
cosa que no havia vist mai en una habitació d'hotel.
Està molt bé, però clar, però mireu quina pols, tio, és que com pots...
No sé, tio, és lamentable, no?
Li dono un 3, un suspès, però no és un 0, perquè, bueno, jo estic caminant i al terra els peus no me'ls embruto de pols, com a mínim.
Part 2 del test, el lavabo.
Malament, també.
No hi ha molta brutícia.
En general, però les juntes estan fatal, m'he dutxat ja, ara està una mica així.
Jo què sé, es veu, no?, aquí.
Algunes taques de calç, no.
Un 4, el lavabo, un 4.
I la part 3 del test és a veure els gensols, a veure si hi ha algun pèl.
A veure, no veig cap pèl, no veig cap pèl.
Vinga.
O sí, mira, aquí n'hi ha un.
Però és molt poc. Ah, no, sí, sí, sí que és un pèl, sí que és un pèl.
Un 4. Per tant, 4 més 4 més 3 dividit entre 3, això què és, un 3,75?
Bastant suspens.
Val, doncs re, tu, avui 21 quilòmetres, no he parlat amb ningú, de moment, perquè ara després aniré a parlar amb un català.
Farem una cerveseta després per la nit.
I amb un altre.
Amb dos catalans. Un que em ve a buscar, em ve a portar uns mitjons, com us he dit abans.
Què més? Re, de diners, bueno, diners crec que 10 euros, amb el gelat i alguna cosa d'altra que m'he comprat.
I aquesta habitació m'ha costat 25 euros per nit.
Són uns 35 euros, més o menys. 180 laris.
Crec que és una mica menys, 70 euros, no ho sé, alguna cosa així.
Gastaré bastant més els propers dies, per tant, ja us ho diré.
I ja està, un cafè i un refresc.
Per fi.
Tornava a faltar el sucre, eh, oi tant?
Bueno, tu, Georgia, top 3 de Georgia, no?
Encara, encara que no us diguis per tot aquest país, però ja podem fer top 3.
El pitjor, els gossos, vale?
El pitjor, els gossos i les comoditats que tenen alguns llogaments que són una mica limitades.
Però el millor seria, top 3, els preus.
Els preus pels lleugosians no són barats, això sempre ho hem de dir, ho hem de tenir en compte, val?
Però per nosaltres, doncs, home, està molt bé.
Georgia es viatja econòmicament, si ets europeu.
Què més?
Top 2. El menjar.
El menjar a Georgia potser et diria que és el millor de tota la volta amb una peu,
però el poso en segon lloc perquè sí que hi ha alguns locals que et donen un menjar que està regular, saps?
Si vas als llocs que està bé, menges increïble.
Però no a tot arreu es menja superbé. Crec que m'explico, no?
Hi ha països on a tot arreu cuinen bé, no?
Per exemple, a Grècia, diria que no vas menjar malament en cap moment.
Però bueno, menjar a Georgia era molt bo.
I top 1, home, evidentment, els paisatges.
Les muntanyes, els boscos, la natura en general, les muntanyes.
Increïble, els paisatges han sigut el punt número 1.
I bona mostra d'això és que hem fet el rècord de desnivell, és a dir,
els dies de més desnivell de la volta amb una peu, acumulat, positiu, han sigut aquí, a Georgia.
Això us ensenyaré les estadístiques que ensenyaré el proper dia. Però sí, sí, han sigut aquí.
Ha sigut dur, per tant. Però m'ho imaginava pitjor en el sentit de calor, eh?
Jo, l'any passat, quan vaig estar aquí, a Georgia, a les muntanyes, no.
Però aquí, a Tbilisi, a cotes més baixes, feia una calor molt brutal.
I la veritat és que fa calor, sí, fa calor, però no és una cosa que et mors.
Per tant, estic tenint bastanta sort amb la mèteo a la volta al món a peu.
Diria que molta. M'ha plogut molt poc, ha fet calor però no exagerat.
A veure com més ara a Centràsia. He mirat les temperatures i pot ser, pot ser bastant brutal.
Doncs això és tot, senyors. Aquí arriba la meva aventura íntegrament a peu.
A partir d'ara ja sabeu que agafaré un avió i continuarem i tal.
Ens veiem al proper vídeo. Salut!